[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لقد كان عرضًا رائعًا للغاية من الرئيس
بوتين وكان بإمكاني أن أقول لا شكرًا لك
أو كان بإمكاني أن أقول شكرًا
لك وقلت سأستقبله والآن حان
الوقت لتقديم زميلي
المميز  -السيد دونالد ترامب ، شكرًا
جزيلاً لك سوزان على وجودك هنا ،
إنه اسم نيكي ، أيًا كان ما تريد
تسميته ، فأنا لا أعرف
كيف سأكافح الأخبار غير الشريفة
كيف يمكنني محاربة مراسل أو
شبكة غير نزيهة تمامًا.
أعلم أنه 100 سلبي لا أستطيع قراءة
هذا التغيير السريع سريع جدًا في
بعض الأحيان سأقول
واو إنها ستكون قصة رائعة
سأكون مراسلة جيدة ليست جيدة كما
أنت
فقط أحب هذه الفكرة على ما أعتقد  يمكنني أن أفعل
ذلك ، إنه بلد رائع
مع أنك تعرف الكثير من الأصدقاء في
روسيا وأنا متحمس جدًا لوجودي هنا ،
فهم لطيفون جدًا ، أجني الكثير من المال
معهم يدفعون لي
الملايين ومئات الملايين
، هذا رائع  واحد هنا جميل
جدار عظيم ولا أحد يبني جدرانًا
أفضل مما أعتقد
أنا وأنا سوف نبني لهم
سورًا
عظيمًا بسعر رخيص جدًا ، وفي حال كنت قلقًا بشأن
من سيدفع ثمنه ، ستدفع المكسيك ثمنها
[موسيقى]
سنرى ما سيحدث ، من يدري
أقول دائمًا من يدري
ولكن  سنرى شعورًا بأننا سننجح في
[موسيقى]